volvemos con más información económica'
entradas en 24 y nos acompaña por
supuesto daniela hablando andan y muy
buenas noches comenzamos en mexico donde
una nueva ley de telecomunicaciones está
causando polémica verdad hola santiago
buenas noches mire el senado de este
país hace unos días aprobó una ley
federal que crea una base de datos que
quedara a disposición de las autoridades
y de seguridad de justicia allí van a
aparecer los datos de los propietarios
de teléfonos móviles incluyendo los
biométricos como huellas digitales y el
iris de los ojos la ley a la que sólo le
falta una casi garantizada sanción
presidencial da un plazo de dos años a
los dueños de más de 120 millones de
líneas para inscribir sus datos y seis
meses para las líneas nuevas quienes no
les reporten quedarán sin servicio los
celulares son un instrumento utilizado
muchas veces en méxico y otros países
para cometer delitos como extorsiones o
secuestros y eso es lo que dice el
gobierno que quiere evitar pero la
oposición está estudiando formas de
apelar el nuevo reglamento pues lo
comparan con espionaje
el mundo santiago ya alrededor de 20
países que ya exigen estos datos
cambiamos de noticia hablemos ahora de
martín guzmán nos el ministro de
economía argentino que finalizó su gira
por europa lleva más de una semana en un
viaje que lo llevó a españa francia
italia y alemania con dos objetivos
hablar de la vacuna spot lake y de las
negociaciones de deuda con los
organismos internacionales pues la gira
determinó después de estos países en
moscú en donde el ministro se reunió con
el vicecanciller para según él
profundizar la cooperación entre ambos
países pero hay un tema de fondo
santiago y es que además de buscar apoyo
internacional para renegociar una deuda
con el fondo monetario internacional
argentina está interesada en producir la
vacuna rusas public en su territorio y
está negociando es los temas claves para
el país
avanzamos ahora a daniela con el tema
que tiene que ver con los derechos
laborales no porque trabajadores de
amazon están denunciando que han
recibido presiones para votar en contra
de la creación de un sindicato es así
verdad claro que si santiago la historia
en la siguiente a principios de este mes
fracasó el intento de los trabajadores
de esta empresa
planta de la mamá para crear el que iba
a ser el primer sindicato de amazon en
eeuu pero la votación arrasó el no con
más de la mitad de los votos el grupo
laboral que la impulsó se opuso
formalmente a los resultados de las
elecciones y denunció que la empresa
amenazó con despedir personal e incluso
con cerrar la planta si prosperaba la
iniciativa la junta nacional de
relaciones laborales de ese país ya está
revisando el caso y la firma dirigida
por el hombre más rico del mundo
besos digo estar muy lista para dar esta
batalla legal ahora ella además de un
año de la declaración de la pandemia de
coronavirus el turismo de vacunas es un
hecho una realidad sin santiago
recordemos que varios países en varios
estados de eeuu a indignación porque
muchas personas están viajando a ese
país para inocularse las autoridades de
algunos estados como florida han
comenzado a exigir pruebas de residencia
para vacunar de manera prioritaria a sus
ciudadanos sin embargo hay un pequeño
archipiélago en el océano índico que
hará realidad este turismo santiago
primero lo hay un dato y es que los
tiquetes son lo más económicos para ir
allá
se trata de maldivas un pequeño país en
asia del sur que es considerado uno de
los destinos de lujo preferidos por los
turistas su gobierno anunció que les
ofrecerá la posibilidad de administrar
las vacunas contra el coronavirus para
añadir un aliciente a su golpeada
industria del turismo este país está
aplicando la vacuna de oxford y
astrazéneca desarrollada en india
también tiene scinopharm in fire y los
turistas podrán elegir cuál usar pero
eso solo va a empezar cuando sus 540 mil
habitantes estén vacunados y cuando
resuelvan un problema de escasez de
dosis hoy menos del 10% ya está
inmunizado y la mitad de la población ya
tiene la primera dosis continuamos con
los indicadores de la jornada que dicen
santiago bolster inició la semana en
rojo marcada por descensos en las
principales tecnológicas en europa la
polémica por la creación de esta
competencia separatista para rivalizar
con la liga de campeones- favoreció
algunos equipos juventus de italia se
disparó en más del 18 por ciento y
manchester united de inglaterra subió
casi 7% tiene américa latina la bolsa de
sao paulo cerró en rojo
pese a que petrobras
para otras la toma de posición de su
presidente nuevo finalizamos como
siempre con la esperada cifra del día
cuales nueve mil millones de dólares
fueron las ventas de coca-cola en el
tercer y en el primer trimestre con un
crecimiento del 5 por ciento pero superó
las expectativas de mercado aunque sus
ganancias cayeron completísima y muy
interesante crónica económica daniela
blandón a ustedes los invitamos a
continuar informando se en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france 24
punto con gracias por acompañarnos